blue origin says all systems are go to
make history tomorrow in west texas
company founder jeff bezos will blast
himself off to the edge of space
in his new autonomous rocket he's
bringing along some friends his brother
mark
82 year old wally funk she's one of the
first women
women rather to train for space flight
that was back in the 60s
and 18 year old oliver damon a dutch
student
whose dad bid for his spot at the
auction mark strossman joins us now
he's near the launch site in van horn
texas mark we saw another billionaire
that's richard branson
go to space last week but this one is a
little different how so
hey gail good morning completely a
different approach bezos is going to fly
in a rocket not inside a space plane
like richard branson did
bezos will also fly about 10 miles
higher than branson did
but his trip is going to be much shorter
only about 10 minutes and this
is also the first time that blue origin
has ever tried to launch
people come on into the capsule
this capsule simulator is the same one
tomorrow's blue origin crew has trained
in
ariane cornell directs sales here for
wannabe astronauts
these are the largest windows that have
ever flown in space
in the emerging space tourism market
blue origin's new shepard rocket
launches vertically its engine generates
110
000 pounds of thrust passengers inside
experience
three g's of force
almost three minutes into flight the
capsule separates and hurtles toward the
heavens
at three times the speed of sound
the reusable rocket booster returns to a
landing pad
more than 60 miles above the planet the
passengers experience
several minutes of weightlessness
microgravity before
returning to earth the fully automated
capsule deploys breaking parachutes
small thrusters fire to slow its descent
and instant before
it touches down in the texas desert this
is a space joy ride
but that's not priority one new shepard
will not launch
until i'm satisfied that it is safe to
do so and i give my go for launch
in a 2019 interview with nora o'donnell
bezos talked about the risk it can never
be
risk-free the only thing that's really
risk-free is like staying in your
bedroom
so the question is is that experience
worth it to you
and for me it certainly is and to other
thrill seekers blue origin's next two
flights are filling up
but the company won't say what it costs
in fact the company is endlessly cagey
about what it costs although we do know
this much the winner of a recent auction
paid
28 million dollars he's not flying this
time
but he will fly on a future flight gail
i guess we'll see you this afternoon
yes i'm getting on a plane coming i'm
excited to see i'll stay on the ground
thank you mark